Hello. And welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host,
Rawkode.
Before we get started,
I just wanna take ten seconds to say
thank you to Equinix Metal. They are my
employer and they allow me to do this
as my job mostly every day. I get
to produce materials that help us all learn
all these awesome cool cloud native projects. Now
you can also try Equinix metal by using
the code Rawkode live.
You can spin up really small boxes which
will get you around a hundred hours of
compute time, but I prefer the more fun
approach, is to spin up the beefy boxes
with almost 400 gigabyte of RAM and spend
that much more
unwisely. Yeah. There we go. So check it
out. If you wanna join the chat, we
have a discord where you can come and
ask questions or suggest future episodes. I please
encourage you to subscribe and thumbs up this
video.
Now today, we're gonna take a look at
the Open Policy Agent. And to do that,
I am joined by no other than the
VP of Open Source for Styra and co
creator of the project, Torin Sando.
Hello, Torin. Hey, David. Thanks for having me.
No. My pleasure. It's gonna be really good.
I'm I'm really looking forward to to playing
with Opal and learn more about it. And
I'm really glad that you're here to be
able to help you do that as well.
So
Yeah. I'm excited.
Would you like to just then take a
moment? You can tell us a little bit
about yourself, about Open and Sarah, and how
that all comes together, and then we'll we'll
talk a little bit more about Open in
more detail.
Yeah. Yeah. For sure. Yes. I'm I'm I'm
Toran. I'm one of the co creators of
the Open Policy Agent Project or OPA,
as we like to call it. So I
I joined Styro almost five years ago to
kinda get the project off the like, start
the project and get it off the ground.
And so I spent spent the last five
years, you know, developing the project,
working on the core, you know, parts of
the project as well as, like, integrations,
taking it and and talking about it at
conferences and writing blog posts.
And and more recently, I've been spending a
lot of time, you know, talking to users
and talking to our customers from start and
helping them just be successful generally. So that's
what I've up to lately. I've spent most
of my career as a as a software
developer working on kind of different kinds of
distributed systems projects to deal with policy and
and and orchestration.
So,
yeah, that's just a little bit about me.
Nice. Yeah.
So can we try and then summarize what
problem does is OPA trying to solve?
Yeah.
Yeah. So OPA is is a is a
policy engine. So what that means is that
it it gives you a way of offloading
policy decision making from your software,
And and that's really it at a high
level. So Open is intended to be
very general purpose and very, very flexible. So
it's really the way to think about it
is it's sort of like a building block
that lets you,
you know, enforce policies
in in like, across the stack, across various
kinds of services,
various systems, various layers, and and and so
on. So there's there's a whole bunch of
different use cases for it.
A lot of the time, it's applied to
problems around authorization.
Right? So controlling
who can do what
at different parts of the stack. Right? So
in Kubernetes,
you know, there's there's role based access control,
and then there's also admission control. Right? So
in Kubernetes,
there's this problem of just putting down kind
of safeguards or guardrails on your Kubernetes cluster
to prevent bad things from happening, to prevent,
you know,
the wrong container images from running, to prevent
workloads from using too much RAM or CPU,
to prevent
developers from accidentally creating ingresses or or, you
know, load balancers on the public Internet and
and and all kinds of things. Right? So
there's this general public admission control in Kubernetes
that Open helps solve.
But you can also use Open in other
contexts. So we see tons of people using
Open for
microservice API authorization,
for for application level authorization,
for enforcing
all kinds of config validation use cases in
CICD pipelines.
Even some people even use it to control
SSH and pseudo access at the host level.
So it's it's it's intended to be very
kind of flexible in general purpose. And and
so
the core of the project is completely domain
agnostic,
but then you can kinda take it and
plug it into different places to solve all
sorts of interesting policy related
problems.
Nice. Okay. So I I I I was
looking at the documentation earlier, and I've seen
that it it had use cases, I said,
at Kubernetes. And some of them you've just
mentioned there, and we'll build the documentation up
shortly. But I'm curious, was the first use
case that you had for Open when you
were building Kubernetes based, or was it something
else altogether?
Yes. We we started the project in, like,
late twenty fifteen, early '20 '16. And at
the time,
yeah, Kubernetes wasn't, like, the de facto standard
for for for container orchestration or just general
kind of, like, config orchestration.
You know, there there were lots of other
competitors at the time, like, and
and
so on. And and
and it wasn't clear, like, who was gonna
win.
But what was clear was that, like and
then cloud native wasn't even a term at
the time. Right? Like or if if it
was, people no one was really using it.
So but but there was this obvious shift
happening where people were adopting, you know, cloud
and and kind of distributed systems at least
are becoming the norm. Right? People are moving
to microservices. People are moving to cloud. They're
automating more and more.
You know, environments are becoming more and more
dynamic and kind of ephemeral.
And so there was a clear need for
a new way of kind of enforcing policies
in the in these sort of modern environments.
And so we we kinda created OPA with
that in mind. So OPA
was sort of designed from the beginning to
be a good fit for distributed policy enforcement,
like being able to take a policy, a
high level policy that says who could do
what or who can access what,
and to then break that down and distribute
it throughout the system and have it kind
of run and execute and be enforced next
piece of software that needs it. That just
happens to be a good fit for for
environments like Kubernetes.
So
it you know, we we we played around
a lot of different use cases early on.
In the early days, as you know, we
we could, like, go look at projects and
we go into the issue tracker,
and, you know, you type in the word
policy and you'd, like, see what would come
back. Right? If you did that in Kubernetes,
you get, like, hundreds of issues. Like, oh,
you know, we wanna we wanna make sure
that our users always supply resource requests and
limits. Right? Or we wanna make sure that,
you know, that that they're not using privileged,
like, kernel capabilities in the in the containers
and stuff like that. Right? And there's just
this long, long list of of what kind
of use cases that we found in Kubernetes,
and so we started to focus our efforts
a little bit
there. Also, at the time, there was no,
like, dynamic way of extending Kubernetes with custom
admission controllers. Like, in order to
in order to implement an admission controller, you
had to write code and then vendor it
into Kubernetes, basically, and then recompile Kubernetes. Right?
So, like, if you're a Kubernetes administrator,
like, maybe you're comfortable doing that, but you
probably don't wanna be doing that at the
very least, right, on a regular basis. So
there wasn't really a great solution, but kinda
came along and and it provided a great
solution because it allows you to just drop
in policies on the fly, have them reloaded
without any kind of restart,
have them applied automatically. So we, you know,
we worked with Kubernetes, like, upstream community, and
and, eventually, webhooks got added,
and and we just integrate nicely into that
that ecosystem.
And, yeah, it just sort of became, like,
a little bit of a standard there.
So something you said there was
that at the core of it, it's agnostic.
Right? It could be used for multiple things.
Is when you say core, do you mean
the DSL, the language, or is that in
reference to something else? Yeah. I just mean
I just mean the the kind of, like,
the
the fundamental, like, concepts around Open. So the
the fundamental thing that it provides you is
this
this this high level declarative language called Rego
that you can use to write your policies
in and then the the the the runtime
for those for that for that language. And
then around that, we build integrations for all
kinds of different systems. So, like, for example,
Gatekeeper is the kind of, like, integration between
OPA and Kubernetes.
We have integrations with Envoy. We have integrations
with PAM. We have integrations with all kinds
of things. There's there's a tool called CoffTest
that's part of the OPA project, which is
really useful for validating config files
inside development environments or inside c I CICD
pipelines.
So
so yeah. So we have the the core
language and runtime, and then around that, there's
there's integrations that that make you actually do
something in the world.
Okay.
Well,
I mean, if we had five hours, I'd
say we'd look at all of that. But
maybe we should narrow the scope a little
bit. So I've got the homepage here, which
should now be visible to everybody.
And we're just gonna click on the documentation.
In fact, there's the playground first. Should we
start there?
Or do you wanna go for should we
go for the docs first?
We I I'm I'm fine with either. The
the playground's a really nice way to just
kinda click around and and see stuff happen.
But
but, yeah, it's it's really I'll I'll leave
it in your hands here. Alright. Okay.
I've opened the playground. I think we'll we'll
use that. We'll we'll kick the tires on
a little bit, and then we'll see how
things are going. If they're going well, maybe
we'll we'll we'll try and deploy gatekeeper or
something. But maybe we should take a look
first
Regal, the the the language. So
this is this how,
you know, some a developer's coming along and
they wanna be able to start using this
to say they don't want any containers to
run as root and say that the Kubernetes
environment. The first thing they're gonna have to
do would be write something in this language
that
that that provided that policy.
Is my understanding that correct?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's right. Yeah. So the
the model that that Open kind of, like,
exposes is is this kind of
this, like, offloading model. So software can query
OPA when it needs to make a policy
decision,
and then and then OPA will will render
a policy decision by evaluating the policies you've
given it and send it send the decision
back to the software to be enforced. So,
like, in the case of Kubernetes,
the API server queries over. It sends across
the wire
this big JSON payload
that has the sort of the full extent
of your in, like, a pod or deployment
or or whatever the object is that you've
configured to go through the webhook. And then
the policy will look at that JSON, and
it'll make it it'll it'll generate
an answer to that policy query that says,
like, deny with this reason. So what you're
doing when you're when you're writing these policies
is you're writing down basically, like, assertions
over or structured data, right,
over over JSON or over YAML, basically. And
so the language gives you a bunch of
primitives to do that. The language is is
is it's declarative, so there's a little bit
of a learning curve with it. But at
the high level, what it what it really
lets you do is just write down if
then statements. You say, you know, deny
is true
if these conditions hold or allow is true
if those conditions hold it and and and
so on. So it's really just about writing
down these if then statements, essentially,
that that
that
look at and kinda, like, analyze
structured data.
Okay.
I mean, I can
having a look at this here, I I
kinda see, like, this combination
of a little bit of goal with the
sustainment operator, but then a little bit of
JSON JavaScript on the right hand side. So
it does feel
pretty familiar on a on a first pass
at it. So and then I can see
here it's got scalars and strength and composite
values. Like,
is it a programming language, or is it
a DSL? Was that a fair distinction to
try and make?
Yeah. I guess,
like, I think DSLs the the term DSL
can mean a lot of different things. OPA
is it's it's a query language, actually. Like,
I don't know. It it follows kinda like
query semantics.
So it's almost closer to, SQL,
essentially, in that you write
you write down statements that express,
like, predicates over over structured data, but that
then generate values.
And so,
you know, you can
you can express all the kinds of things
you would expect in a query language. Like,
you can express ands and ors. You can
express search operations.
So, like, for example, if you had
you know, in a pod, there's, a list
of containers. Right? And so you might wanna
search over that list and see if any
of the containers
specify image from a registry that you don't
want, right, or or or from, like, a
registry that's not allowed. Right? And so the
language has these these kind of, like, concepts
baked into it to allow you to do
those kinda, like, search operations. And then there's
a bunch of other kind of features that
that come into play that are policy related,
like the ability to compose and delegate and
and so on. Okay.
I'm assuming the language didn't come before any
sort of proof of concept. Open anything like
that. Was there an actual version YAML, and
you maybe had some constraints there that you
had to break it out into Rego? Or,
like, how how did that come about?
Yeah. I I think there's like, someone is
at some point, someone said, like, you know,
the best advice around DSLs is, like, don't
create them or, you know, don't don't start
because it's a it's a big project. Right?
You you need to
you need to come up with, like, a
well defined semantics for the language. You need
to implement a runtime for that, and you
need build all the tooling around it. It's
it's it's it's a lot of work. And
so,
like, early on, we actually, you know, experimented
with a lot of things. We we even
we we tried to use SQL, for example,
as as as the language for expressing these
policies. And we just ran into a lot
of like, we ran into issues,
especially around dealing with, like, structured or, like
like, nested hierarchical data like JSON. Right? And
since JSON is just sort of or JSON
or YAML or any kind of, like, hierarchical
structured data is so prevalent in modern systems.
Right? Like, we use it configuration. We represent
all of our API objects with it. Right?
It just it was it was like, it
necessitated something something new.
The the actual, like, language and ethics behind
Open and Riga are are based on this
thing called Datalog,
which are which is, like, well kind of
very well understood.
And we sort of layered the ability to
deal with JSON or structured data or hierarchical
structure data on top of that.
Alright. Thanks.
So we have our first comment from Moz
who says, the regular language is very complicated.
Please share some hints or tips. Well, we're
gonna do our best to kinda break that
down just now and today. So we'll be
taking a look at some examples and and
hopefully that helps you, Moz.
So we have this Regal playground,
has loads of examples that we can dive
into. But this let me zoom in on
that a little bit.
There you go.
And the documentation here, I mean, this looks
pretty good. So this is just a hello
world.
See if I can work this one out.
So the default value for low is false.
We pass some input
and m equals world.
No.
Alright.
I don't think I understand what this is.
Do you wanna maybe just give me a
little bit of understanding here? Help me work
this for that. Yeah. For sure. So here,
why don't just just to
well, first, just click evaluate on the top
right.
Alright.
Alright. So the so the output from this
was hello is true.
The reason why hello is true is that
when the policy was evaluated, the statements on
line twenty four and twenty five were were
satisfied by the inputs. You can see on
the top right, the input is a JSON
object that has a key message and a
value
world. And then in that rule, on line
23,
we basically assigned a message to an intermediate
variable m, and then we've checked if m
is equal to world. And so,
you know, if you just kind of, like,
look at that and then look at the
input, you'd realize, yes. Okay. Those those statements
on the in that rule are true.
What's going on here is is there's a
little bit of implicit behavior. So, like, on
line 23,
right after hello, if you wrote equals true
right after hello,
that would mean exactly the same thing. So
so that way you just the way you
change the policy hasn't changed the meaning of
the policy at all.
You can click evaluate, and it'll it'll it'll
give you the same output.
We allow you to just omit equals true
from the head of a rule because
it's so common, basically. So when you leave
out the value there, it just means true.
It just says,
hello is true if
the conditions in the body are are true.
So hello is true if
m
can be assigned to input dot message and
m equals
world. So the it it that's why I
said it's basically all just a bunch of
if then statements. You're basically just saying
assign a value to a variable
if the conditions in the body of the
rule are true. There's two parts to a
rule. There's a head and a and a
body. The head is the assignment,
basically,
and the body are the conditions that you
write
inside of the rule. So this is just
saying hello is true if
input dot message equals equals world,
and you can leave that off. And then
there's this notion of undefined, which we can
get into later. But, basically, if for some
reason, the value so, like, in this case,
if the value mess of message wasn't world,
then the question is, well, what should hello
be? And that's what default allows you to
do. It allows you to assign a default
value to a variable when none of the
none of the rules with that name match.
So, like, if you change the input in
this case,
if you change world to something else,
anything else, and evaluate,
now hello is false. Right? Because the statements
in that body
are no longer satisfied.
Alright. That helps.
There that that immediately helps me because I'm
gonna just test I'm gonna change something because
I wanna confirm something in my head. So
if I since there's to be a string,
I want to say, like so by default,
hello would be Torin and otherwise,
David, and then I change this to world.
Now the reason I did that is because
I wanted to change the tapes system here
because Mhmm.
He said this could be a MEDI. And
what I actually thought was happening there was
this final
thing was an expression return in a billion
value, but it's not the case. What's actually
inside of these parentheses is just a number
of statements which either true or false dictate
how the assignment of this happens. If they're
all true, then we make an assignment, and
there's an implicit true. But, otherwise,
it would be the default value.
Yep. So the state so so the way
that you can kinda read that, it's it's
language is very light on syntax. There's not
a lot a lot of syntax. It's very
minimal.
The way you can kinda read it is,
you know, hello is David
if
and then the the statements inside the body
of the rule. And the statements inside the
body of the rule are anded together. So
they all need to be true or
basically, like, what we call defined in order
for
the value to be to be generated.
Okay. Cool. And so you can you can
actually and so there's a couple couple of
things that fall out of that. One is
that you can generate any JSON value. So
that like, you've generated strings here. We were
generating booleans before, but, right, JSON allows you
to express objects that contain arrays, that contain
objects, and, you know, and so on and
so forth. Right? So you can generate any
JSON value from a from a rule,
actually. And you can actually include variables as
well. So, like, if you changed David to,
like, m in this case
and you ran that, it would output world,
basically. So you can include variables in the
head of the in the head of the
rule. You can generate dynamic values this way.
Cool.
The other thing that's sort of important to
notice here is that this rule that we've
got is it's called hello.
Right?
Hello is not baked into OPA in any
way. Right? And neither is allow or deny
or or or permit or or block or
anything like that. So
all of the c's are these are these
kind of variable assignments. Right? And so you
can you can actually this is really powerful
because it means that you can build up
kinda helper rules or abstractions that, like, up
level the
the problem and and kind of, like, allow
you to create
your own kind of, like, model for for
the for the policy. And so if you
look at some of these other examples, you'll
you'll see that in action.
Okay.
Before I do that, let's just finish on
one thing from this example.
The there's a little bit of vocabulary there
that I was picking up as as we
were talking. So variables are variables. I think
that's fine.
This hello is
a rule.
And do we have are these expressions,
statements, conditions, predicates? Is there something that we
we refer to them as? Yeah. Yeah. So
we we so if you select, like, hello
all the way down to that closing brace,
we call that whole thing a rule, basically.
Correct. There are two parts to the rule.
There's the head and the body.
The head is the assignment portion,
and the body is the are the conditions.
The the or expressions, I should say. So
so the each line in the in the
body is what we call an expression,
but you could call it a condition. It
doesn't really really make a difference.
Makes sense.
So there's there's two parts to it.
And
and yeah. And then there's a there's different
you know, the basically, like, Rego allows you
to express
there there's
JSON types. Right? So strings, numbers, booleans, null,
arrays,
and objects. And then also, we add sets.
So you can actually there's set literals in
the language.
And then it's got that that thing you
see on line 24 on the right. That's
what we call a reference. So you're actually,
like, referring into
a JSON document in this case. And you
can actually you know, you can do exactly
what you'd imagine. Right? It's dot into deeply
nested structures. So if this was a, you
know, a pod or a deployment, right, you'd
have to dot several levels into
something in order to look up the value.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Nice. Okay. Is there
does it mind about the types? Like, if
I set this back to true and we
return a string, is that perfectly okay? That's
perfectly fine. Yeah. Yeah. You can do that.
Yeah. Nice. Okay. Let's switch the example then
and pick something a
little bit more
exciting. Shall we
dive straight into the some Kubernetes stuff? Sure.
Yeah. Yeah. Why don't we? Let's go to
the hello world one. Okay.
Alright.
Alright. So we have some kind of concept
of of packages, composability,
something I can I can fetch? How how
does that work with a regular and an
open?
Yeah. So
all of the all of the rules that
you that you write so in this case,
we've got a rule called deny, and I'll
get into how that how that's working in
a minute. But
all of the rules that you write are
namespaced
inside of a package.
So the package basically provides, like, a a
grouping or a namespacing of of the rules
you write,
which means that you can kind of like,
you can decompose a policy into a bunch
of different namespaces or packages and then delegate
ownership
to different namespaces. So in this case, we've
we've written a rule called deny. We put
it inside the namespace of the package. Kubernetes
validating label. And so if you wanted to,
like, look up the value of deny, you
would ask for it under that under that
package.
So this is this is what allows you
to kind of have policies from different groups
of people
brought together and then stitched together and then
and then and then ultimately, to produce a
single
kind of decision.
And so this Okay. Yeah.
I I was actually just playing around. Obviously,
I think it was it was at the
start of this week, maybe the end of
last week, but there was the whole helm
to deprecation and the helm not disappearing and
the artifact top. And I actually noticed there
were open policies available through
that as well, which I thought was great.
I never thought of it it being
packages I could ship so that we only
write it once and pass around. So that's
Exactly. Yeah. So you can you can use
this to to break the policy down into,
like, sub policies that then get stitched together.
You can also use it to create like,
you can you can define functions in Rego
as well. So you can define, like, helper
functions for for all kinds of things. Like
like, let's say you want a function that
parses a docker tag, right, into the the
repo and the registry and the, you know,
you know, so on and the and the
the version or whatever the tag. You could
write that logic in Rego
as a function and then
ship that around or reuse that inside of
your your policies, and all of it is
based on this packaging model.
Okay. Nice.
So let's take a look at this deny
then. So we haven't seen these
square brackets yet. Is this a function with
a variable being passed in?
Yeah. So this is this is a sort
of. So so you can think of it
as a function. This is basically this is
just another rule. The difference between this rule
and the one you saw before
is that this is the this is what
we call a partial rule, which essentially allows
you to assign a set of values to
a variable. So instead of assigning a single
value to a variable, this allows us to
define a set of values, so multiple values
under the same variable name.
And so the reason why this is useful
in the context of Kubernetes
and the reason why you'll see a lot
of these, like, deny rules in Kubernetes or
violation rules in Kubernetes that are structured like
this is that it means that you can
create multiple definitions of deny
that all kind of act like, conceptually
add into the set.
So in this case, we're saying
is a set that will contain message,
MSG, if the conditions in the body of
the rule hold in the and then, like,
inside the body of the rule, we're we're
basically, like, looking up to see whether the
the cost center
is there.
And if it doesn't start with the right
string, then we generate an error message and
put it into the set. And so if
you evaluate the policy, you'll see that deny
is is not just a string in this
case, but it's it's a it's a set,
or we represent sets as JSON arrays
when we serialize that. But yeah. Okay. So
this is a set of
I mean, if if this was goal, this
would be true and
excuse my typing. And then we just be
saying deny
message.
Yeah. We say there's a set deny. We
add into that set or something. Right? Equals
blah blah blah. Okay. Right. That makes sense.
Okay. Yeah.
This is checking that the
the YAML we pass into it has some
sort of certain structure. There's nothing to say
what type of YAML this is, but does
that mean if I pass in a YAML
structure that doesn't have request object metadata, like,
say it doesn't have anything below object, was
that just an immediate deny, or is that
an error?
Or It's not an error. No. So it
would just be undefined. So, basically, if you
refer to a value that doesn't exist, then
it then that that reference is just undefined.
Right? There's no value there. It's not it's
not an empty string. It's not an empty
object. It's not it's not even null because
that's a valid JSON value. It just it's
just undefined. It doesn't exist.
And when something is undefined or it doesn't
exist, then the statement is just not true.
Like, it's just not there. Right? So in
order for this message to be added into
into deny, that field has to exist. That
path has to exist in the in the
JSON.
Okay. Well, I'm I'm getting heckled already to
click evaluate.
Adrian. I'll get that done now.
So we evaluate these rules, and I we'll
go back over that in a second, and
we get deny because it does not contain.
Well, no. It does contain a call center,
but it's not formatted correctly.
Exactly. Yeah. So what this is expecting
does that dash have to exist? It's yeah.
So that would be
that should work.
K.
That's right. Yes? Yep. Yeah. Yeah. Got you
got it.
Alright. So now I wanna test the what
I was talking about there is if we
remove the request and I see a response
because I'm a terrible developer.
Yeah. There's no error. There's there's a rules
just the same. Doesn't happen. The rules don't
pass and the denies and checked. Exactly. Yeah.
If you go to the examples, there's another
one that kinda gets into this. So
label exists. Let's go to go to that
one. This this builds on the what we
were just looking at.
So so this one this policy this example
has two denier rules in it. So there's
one denier rule that's checked on the bottom
that's checking if the call center label is
present and that it has the right format.
But we've added another rule on top of
above.
The order doesn't matter, but we've added another
rule that's just checking whether that field exists
at all, and it's generating a different error
message in that case. So if you if
you do the same test now,
we'll see the output is a little bit
different.
Every reason. So So this this one doesn't
have that that cost center label in it,
I think. Yeah. There we go. Yep.
Ah, okay.
Okay. So the row are the rows executed
top to bottom? Is there any sort of
ordering semantics there? No.
So yeah. So there there is no ordering
across across the rules, and there's no ordering
within the rules either. Right? The the statements
the expressions in the rule are just added
together. Right? There's no order with with an
and.
And and what we've done here is we've
actually expressed logical or. Right? So we've said
deny contains message if
not input request yada yada yada or
deny contains message if,
you know, the value does not start with
that code. So,
yeah, when you define a rule multiple times
with the same name, that's how that's that's
an expression of logical or, essentially. We've we've
said add this message into the set if
or add it into the set if.
Ah, okay. Alright.
It's it's it's starting to get there. I'm
I'm learning. So
let's move on to this next one then,
image safety.
Now now that I'm an expert at this,
let's see.
So
no. I did as we were talking at
the start, I accidentally clicked on a doc,
which happened to reveal what the sum statement
was. The
universe because I I seen universal quantification. I
was like, alright. I need to click on
this one.
So I know that this means there's gonna
be some list of values that we wanna
iterate over. And now we're checking if it
is a pod,
and we're checking
so we're seeing here that all images must
come from hooley.com,
if I've read that right.
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. So this this example is
saying, let's put a policy in place that
says that all container images
must come from a corporate registry. Right? And
you you could express that. Like, you could
invert the logic and say, like, only allow
if. But in this case, we've expressed it
as a as a deny list. So we've
said, if there are any images that don't
come from hooley.com, then there's some sort of,
like, error or warning that needs to occur.
Now the interesting thing about this example
is that as every as you probably know,
the pods can contain multiple containers.
And those containers
are specified as an array.
Right? And so
you could write a policy that goes and
says, okay.
Input request objects that container zero
dot image equals
or must equal something.
And then write another rule that says
spec dot containers one and then another one
that says spec dot containers two.
Right? But that would obviously be
painful
and and impossible in some cases. Right? If
you don't know the number of
containers that could possibly exist, then you'd have
to write an infinitely long list of these
these statements, and no one's got time for
that. So the way that we get around
that in Rego is is by doing iteration.
Okay? And so the the this is this
is probably the hardest concept in all of
Rego is is, like, just understanding iteration because
it's not explicit like you might be used
to if you're, like, writing Python code or
JavaScript code. It's it's more implicit in the
same way that it's implicit in, like, SQL.
And so what we've what we this this
example kinda gets into that. So what we
do here
is we declare a variable. In in, Regal,
you use the keyword some
to declare a variable.
And so we say for some I,
if the input
contains a pod
and for some I where we u we
inject I into that reference. This is like
an array index now. For some array index
I,
containers of array index i.image
does not start with hulu.com and generate an
error. So this will basically iterate over all
of the containers
in the pod
and check whether any of them
are check which ones don't start don't start
with
that string.
So if we evaluate this, you can see
MySQL
is not from
Okay.
So can I ask a question? Yeah.
So
can at the end, this can be any
JSON object. Right? Or any JSON.
Is that would that be correct? So if
I were to make this a list Mhmm.
And just actually copy it and then had
to evaluate, will that check both of those
admission reviews?
No. No. So so what's happened now is
that so so, yeah, you're right that it
it could be a JSON value. So the
important thing to keep in mind is that
OPA doesn't know anything about Kubernetes
pods or Kubernetes admission control objects. Right? It's
just a JSON blob that's been passed to
OPA that that the policy is evaluating against.
And a policy is what what applies meaning
to that JSON data. Right? So Open itself
just sees JSON,
but the policy
looks at that JSON and
applies meaning to the to the values in
in the in the JSON. And so in
this case,
you you've changed the input, so you've changed
it from an object to an array.
And that's that's totally fine. It's just that
the the the policy is now kind of,
like, out of sync with the data that's
being passed in. Right? So in this case,
we're assuming that the input is an object.
We could we could treat it as an
array. And so,
yeah, we can make the change. So if
we chain we Can I try and let
me see if I can do this in
June? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm gonna define a second sum. I'm gonna
make my
where does that live here? Request.
I don't know if it'd be input or
request. I'll let you fix that in a
second and then change this to j just
so it's an order. Is
that pretty close?
It it it's close. Yeah. So there's just
two things to two things to observe here.
Right? So one is that we've got two
statements in this in this rule that are
referring to input. Right? So there's line 25
or that are referring to that JSON data.
There's line 25 and line 26.
Right? So we want that we'd want both
of those to be the same.
The other thing to observe here is that
in this case, like, I think the way
you change the input data, like, you just
made the top level input value an array.
You scroll up
in the input field. Yeah. So we just
oh,
yeah. Yeah. There we go. So the way
that you refer to the to the JSON
data is exactly the same as the structure
of the JSON data. Right? So in this
case, like, would we we now I'll flip
it around and ask you a question. Do
we wanna iterate over request, or do we
wanna iterate over input? Yeah. There you go.
Alright. Yeah. So I was thinking that when
I was typing that. Was like, well, it'll
a better request with input. But yeah. So
what's this
work?
It did. Yep.
Nice. And so now if you had if
you I mean, you can copy that that
JSON object if you want, and and you'll
see multiple answers come back.
How do you mean? Sorry? In the input.
So if you just take the input, the
object oh, you did. Okay. I thought, yes.
There should be oh, but I assume Role
is broken, so I'm assuming. So change the
second one. How about you change the second
one to be a different image, like,
engine? Ah, okay. So, yeah, let's set to
MariaDB.
Sure. There we go.
K.
Yeah. Nice. Yeah. So now we're searching over
all the vision objects in this array, and
then we're searching all over all of the
containers. So it
it's pretty powerful. Right? Like, we've just expressed,
like, a nested for loop here just by
putting variables into those into those references.
I mean, I can reference any
other variable here too. And could I just
say that this came from
image
button name? Oh, no. That would just be
name. Right? So Yep. But you can refer
to the container name if you wanted to.
You could you could either assign it to
a yeah. You can run that. Okay.
So now this this now we've an error
back. It's telling us, woah. Wait wait a
second. Right? So it's saying that the variable
name is unsafe.
All that means is that name hasn't been
assigned anywhere,
basically. Right? And so
that's that's not good. So we need to
assign name to some value
if we wanna use it. Ah, okay. So
down here, I would just say this is
equal to input.
I'll just copy that. We don't need to
watch me type
that.
Name.
Oh, alright. And then we have image my
SQL.
Okay.
I didn't really make it proper English sentence.
But we now have the container image name
and the container name. So nice. Like, I
can see how you can start to put
all these things together. So that's great.
Okay. So we have one more Kubernetes example,
but maybe we could just go through the
steps of like the playground is great. But
what would my developer local machine kinda workflow
look like? Or
and
Yeah. I mean, I'm assuming I can run
this on my own machine. I don't need
to copy and paste all of my my
JSON or YAML to Yeah. Totally. But this
is actually a great opportunity to try something
out from the playground, which is to click
publish on the top right. I
did look at that button, and I was
like, I wonder what that means. So
Okay. So when you when you publish a
policy in the playground, it just gives you
a shareable link. So this is a great
way, like, if you're experimenting with something and
you wanna give it to somebody and for
them to look at or you're filing an
issue against OPA or you have a question,
you know, put in the playground, share the
link,
give it to us. We can we can
look at it there. But we also give
you the steps to take this and run
it locally on your local OPA.
And so
we can go through this right now if
you want, but this this allows you to
basically
run OPA locally.
And then what it'll do actually is it'll
download the policy from the playground, and then
it'll let you interact with it locally.
You obviously do all this development locally, but
I just thought I'd kinda highlight this, which
is a a neat feature, I think, of
of the playground.
Okay. So are
these two separate options? One of them is
to run an open server locally
Mhmm. Point to
search resource. And then this one is just
to actually download the policy.
The yeah. The first one, it will run
OPA, and it'll basically configure it to use
what we call bundles in OPA. So bundles
are the way that you kinda distribute policies
and data down to the OPA. So what
it's gonna do is it's run OPA. It's
gonna configure it to pull the policy from
the playground.
And then the second thing there is showing
you how you can exercise the o like,
the policy locally on your machine via the
OPA that's gonna be running there on your
on your laptop or on your on your
desktop here.
Okay. So I should just copy this link
here then. Yep. You can just run that.
Here we go. So Open's running. It's downloaded
the policy
from the playground.
In this case, you can the the bundle
API is very simple. You can just serve
bundles on NGINX or on s three or
on any HTTP server, and they're just g
ZIP tarballs that contain policy and data files.
So it's very
HTTP friendly.
And then,
yeah, and then you can just run that.
That's gonna be the playground will serve the
input data that's that's that's there. So if
you
it's just doing some some curl magic, but
it's basically just downloading the input data from
the playground and then sending it to the
local.
Didn't it like that? Oh, it's just me
trying to pave it through Oh, no. No.
Yeah. JQ. Just give give JQ
wait.
Why didn't it?
Does that not work? What is it? Parse
it. ZSH parse error in here.
It's just the lane to endings. Maybe. Yeah.
Yeah. I think so. We go. Yeah.
So now you're getting a response from the
local OPA on
your machine.
Okay. So so just so that I understand
that correctly, when I run this OPA server
command here, the only policies is aware of
is a bundle that has been served by
the playground.
That's right. So I can just throw any
JSON
data at this most local server at the
data endpoint, and that's gonna run those policies
against it. Exactly. Locally on your machine.
Right. Okay. Cool.
That's a that's a neat feature.
Especially,
could see, you know, if people are struggling
to get their policies to work or to
test them or whatever, you know, been able
to just throw them up there and pass
them around. I can see definitely a lot
of value in that for sure.
So
let's
so do I always have to run an
open server?
No. So you can you can use OPA
in a few different ways. So
now that you have OPA on your machine,
maybe this is a good opportunity to just
kinda, like, play around with it locally.
So
if you just run OPA, it'll it'll do
the standard thing of showing you the different
commands that are available.
OPA kinda like say,
like, embodies the idea of policy as code.
So it gives you a a kind of
like a a tool chain that you can
use to interact with the policies locally on
your machine on the command line. So there's
there's tooling to, like, parse the policies, check
them, build up bun those bundles that I
was talking about, as well as just run
the policies. So if you just type overrun,
what it'll do is drop you into a
a local shell or, like, a what we
call a repo or read about print loop.
So this allows you to just run
arbitrary statements inside the policy language and then
and then see the output of them.
So you can go and define, like yeah.
Exactly. You can find a rule called hello,
and then you can ask for hello if
you just type hello now.
It'll it'll print the value of hello. Right?
So this is just what we call the
REPL. It's a sort of a low level
way of of interacting with the policies. You
can
if you do overrun and you you can
pass in files,
it'll load those up, and then you can
query them. You can interact with them. And
is that just a fail with, like, a
policy statement like here? Yeah. Yeah. So grab
like, why don't you grab this one
and just dump that into a a dot
rego file on your machine?
Call it man.
Is this Versus code, by the way? Yeah.
Is. Yeah. Okay. There we go. Nice. Perfect.
Alright. There we go. That's what I wanted
to test.
Need those colors for sure.
Yeah. It gives you colors and a little
bit more, actually. So it gives you all
the same stuff that you saw on the
playground. So that ability to, like, evaluate the
policy, you get that inside of the SQL.
Yeah. It's looking much better now. There we
go. There we go. That's beautiful.
So now yeah. Let's exit the rep. So
now that I have our main dot rego
there, I'm assuming I can just do open
run and then I'll just do help. Oh,
it's quite a lot though. Okay. So
so you just pass it fails. Perfect.
So if I type show oh, no.
So yeah. When you type show in the
in the REPL, what it does is it
any rules you've defined inside the the REPL.
The cool thing about the REPL is that
you're just writing queries.
So
okay. Guess one thing we didn't talk about
before is that all the rules that you
write and all the data that you load
into OPA is is namespaced under what we
call the data documents. There there are two,
what we call, documents in in OPA. There's
the input document which you're interacting with before.
That contains the value that the software occurring
OPA wants to send across. And then there's
the data document, which represents
it's basically all of the decisions and all
of the raw data that's cached inside of
Open that are loaded into Open. So if
you just type data,
it'll show you the value of all of
the rules that you've got
inside of the inside of the policy. And
so you can see that
it's opening this hierarchy. That hierarchy might look
familiar if you if you think back to
what was in the policy in that package
statement.
So the package defines
the location in the data document where your
rules will appear. And so in this case,
the package is Kubernetes dot validating dot images.
So that means that denial will show up
under Kubernetes validating
images
inside of the data document.
Okay. So how do I
actually validate a document then with this rule
that we've we've run over with?
So right now, the the inside the Ruffle,
we don't have an input document defined.
So when you run the policy, it's not
matching anything. So we can define an input
document in the Repl package just by typing
input,
like, colon equals
some value. Now you'll need to paste in
that thing from the from the playground in
order for this to to do the right
thing, and that should work, hopefully. Yep. Okay.
So now if you now now we've defined
a rule called input, and there's a
a convention in the around
input, like, order to how you define it.
So
just trust me that it's defined without input
document.
If you run data again, you'll you'll see
Oh, there we go. Oh, sorry. It's dumping
both the input value. So type, like, data
dot Kubernetes for example. Okay. So Yeah. There
you go. Yeah.
Yeah.
So what it's doing when you when you
run that is it's internally grabbing the value
of the input document to use, and then
it's running that that query
against the input value.
Okay. Very cool. Now
what about from
a CI perspective?
Let's assume maybe this isn't the way that
it works, but let me try and
see what I've got in my head. I
can imagine I have a project that has
some Kubernetes YAML things. And let's just say
there's a rules folder with the rules Regal
files and then there's a manifest folder with
the manifests on it. And I want my
CI system to run the rules against the
manifest. Is is there a workflow for doing
that?
Yeah. So there's there's different ways you can
do it.
On the command line with OPA, we have
this thing called OPA eval,
which lets you just run
like, it's it's basically like running the REPL,
but just on the command line. So you
can you can run a policy query
against
against a bunch of data and and and
policy files.
But it's a bit it's kinda low level.
I I can show you. So if you
just go back to the command line
Yep. And you type
open eval.
So this is similar to to what you
just did, but if you do
dash d,
so for for data or policy, and you
pass in main dot Rego,
and then dash I for input, so now
we can give it
oh, we didn't save that file to this.
I did. I got it. I'm sorry. You
got it. Alright. Perfect.
And then you do and and now you
can give it a query. So now if
you run data, just just type data.
If
you run that, it'll
yeah. Exactly. It'll it'll return the output.
Right. So you can you can run the
policies locally
using
using Open Eval.
Again, that's sort of like a Swiss army
knife for evaluating your policies. So there's all
kinds of options that it supports for, like,
doing tracing
and profiling and and other things.
But it's really meant to be just like
a Swiss army knife. And you can build
you could build, like, scripts around that that
would do
what you want in your CICD pipeline.
But it's it's a low level tool. And
so this is where, like, the CONF test
subproject comes in. So conf test provides, like,
a more opinionated way of, like, loading and
and running your your policies on the command
line. And so with conf test, you would
just say, I think, conf test
test, and then you pass in the manifest.
So it would automatically load up the data
the policy files and then run them against
your
your your
your manifest. So it it's a much more
kind of, like, developer friendly, I would say.
So using contest, does that provide a sort
of workflow where, you know, say it's maybe
like a a a standard company set up
with us, an operations team that defined the
policies in the central location, and then the
developers wanna run contest locally to see if
it passes? That's that would enable that kind
of workflow where I could say, hey. Go
and test my stuff against those rules.
Yep. So so a lot of the time,
what people will do is they'll have it
run as, a pre merge hook in in
Git or as part of, you know, as
part of CI. Right? So after
the manifest merged or even before, they'll have
contest run against against all the manifests in
in the Git repo. Right? And so they'll
the leader store the policies in the same
repo, or you can also pull them from
another another place. And so contest supports, like,
pulling from Git, pulling from
OCI registries,
as well as well as other options. So
it's it's pretty flexible in terms of how
it obtains the policies.
And then and then it'll it'll run them
against whatever files you've you've fed into it.
So it's a really nice way of of
doing kind of,
like, CICD time validation. And then, yeah, if
you wanna try it out locally on your
laptop, you can do that because it's
it's portal. That's one of the things that
we
spent a lot of time
ensuring early on in, like, development of Open
was that the policies you write ought to
be portable. I mean, you can take them
and you can, like, run them in your
Kubernetes cluster, but you can also run them,
you know, inside of a CICD pipeline just
as just as well. You can run them
offline for, like, audit purposes, for example. So
Nice. Okay.
So
let's see.
Does it make sense now?
Can
should we try and deploy this to our
Kubernetes and then do some enforcement,
or is there something else that are more
another step you think we should take here?
No. I think this is this is pretty
good. One one one of the features that
we didn't exercise, I think, in the playground
and that you get in Versus Code that
is, I think, really cool is is the
interactive evaluation. So you're, like you were clicking
actually, you can kinda see it now. I
don't know if you've caught it, but that
button up there changed.
It no longer says evaluate. It says evaluate
selection.
Ah.
And so what that means is that you
can actually select
parts of the policy. Oh, you've gone straight
to the really cool example.
Yeah.
So
yeah. So you could select you could click
evaluate selection now.
And what it does is it prints the
values of the variables that are selected inside
of that text block. Right? So it's giving
us all the values of I and j
and name and image, and it's it's reporting
that back.
So you can select basically any statement inside
the policy and and evaluate it and get
back the the current value. So, like, if
you just select deny, for example,
and then evaluate selection,
you'll just get back the value of deny.
When you run evaluate without selecting anything, what
it's doing is it's just basically just asking
for all the values of all the rules
inside the file.
But you can just as well ask for
a single rule or as you just saw
yeah. So if you run that, we've only
selected message. Right? And message isn't defined anywhere.
Right? So it's it's not safe. But yeah.
So there there's some limitations to that. Obviously,
you can't just select anything, but you can
select any expression,
any rule name,
any set of expressions inside the same rule.
Okay. Yeah. And I was wondering if it
would show me the
the violation
in some way. But
You would need to select mess the last
line in there as well. Yeah.
There we go.
Nice.
Yeah. Yeah. So that that interactive evaluation feature,
I think, is is is really powerful. It
creates a really tight, like, development loop or
a test loop when you're when you're developing
a policy or debugging a policy.
You can do it in the playground. You
can do it inside Versus Code.
You're in the rep, but it's a little
bit more low level. So yeah. So I
can do that in code as well? You
can. Yes.
You'll need to make sure that you have
Open installed in path in the path, but
the plugin ought to do that for you,
actually.
Yeah. Just blew up a oh, you're oh,
yeah.
It may work. It should work.
Don't know. It's taking some time. I'm scared.
Well, I'm running big, sir. It seems to
have slowed everything down. So Oh, really?
Oh, there we go. Okay. Alright.
Well, I mean, it's
thinking about it now. It's consider it's considering
whether it's a wide
I didn't ask it to go and update
all the the history. I just wanted it
to install a package, but whatever. Okay. So
now we have open our path,
means I should be able to do this.
Yep.
Let's see. Do I have some sort of
I do. Okay. Evaluate selection, evaluate package. So
let's try
this evaluate
action.
So
that's
interesting that it magically pulled that JSON failure
of my project
and ran the rules
against it.
How do you guys do that? So so
show me the show me the
well, yeah. So you've got this inside of
a directory or something. Yeah. I've got an
input dot JSON. Oh, there we go. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So the convention in Versus code is that
the input document will be pulled from input
dot JSON.
And by default, it'll just load up every
Rango file inside the workspace.
So,
yeah, so it just magically worked. So I
just got ridiculously lucky with the name of
that failed and for that to actually work.
Yeah. I mean, all of our all of
our examples say input.JSON,
and so when we were The subliminal messaging.
Yeah. Yeah. What you wanna call that fail?
You were tricked into
We didn't prepare this in any way for
the records.
No. But now I need to rename it
because I always have to see it not
work before Yeah. Not perfect.
Alright. No input files. Okay.
Okay.
There
we go.
Okay. That it's really cool that I get
all of that features as well locally. I
can see how is it it could really
quick feedback loop. I can just throw in
an input dot JSON and make it work.
Now does it care about it being JSON
if I renamed that to input dot YAML?
Are the same rules gonna be applied against
that?
That's a good question.
I don't think Should we just try it?
Yeah. Try it. I I think it I
think it's gonna fail.
We can load input files,
or we can load files like YAML files
through other APIs, but I think this one's
not gonna work. We can try, though.
Look. We're gonna get a great error message
here. I can I can already see it?
Well, Arena missed the input too.
Yeah. And let's try our
evaluate.
Alright. Okay. Yeah. No input. It didn't find
it. Yeah.
But pull requests are always welcome. So if
somebody wants to come along to the the
Versus Code plugin and give us that,
you know, we'd love to take it.
Awesome. That's really cool. Really impressed with that
plugin, actually. I don't I I don't even
think that that would be something we've been
playing with, but it's kind of really helps
work out what my workflow is gonna be
when I'm starting to put these policies together
on my own machine without having to work
from the playground as it would be. Mhmm.
Cool.
Alright.
Is there anything else you wanna wanna cover
before we finish up?
The only other thing that just occurred to
me that we really think is really powerful
about over is the ability to test your
policies, right, unit tests
for your policies.
So what we've been doing right now is
just kinda playing with it. Right? We've been
kinda, like, just poking around and and clicking
buttons and and kinda seeing what happens, which
is a great way to get started. But
when we when you when we write down
policies and rules,
just like code,
it's really powerful to be able to write
down tests for that for that code. And
so OVA comes with, like, a whole test
framework that allows you to write unit tests
for your rules and then to have those
tests run inside of Versus Code or on
the command line.
And so that's just something else I would
recommend people kinda take a look at. There's
a whole page on the in the documentation
that that goes into that.
It's it's it's in terms of that, like,
fast feedback loop that we've been talking about,
it's a really, really powerful way of accelerating
development. And, I mean, you get a regression
suite out of it automatically by doing this.
But yeah. So I highly highly recommend
people invest in test driven development when they're
working with with regular policies. It it really
speeds things up.
And because
because the language is is a kind of
a query language and because values are just
kind of first class,
you can you can really quickly get a
% coverage, and it really speeds up your
your kind of iteration time. So
definitely definitely check that out.
I mean, I'm gonna try it now. Alright.
Let's go.
Sure. Sure I could do this in two
minutes. We have a a couple of comments
as well. So Adrian has said, thank you
for this. It reminds me a bit of
x and l s t and prologue,
but it's been a long time. Yeah.
And maybe you just want to integrate Rego
into a container registry so you can run
it on image manifest. Yeah.
That's actually a cool idea. I haven't
if anybody's
brought that up. Yeah, it would be nice
to have that kind of same admission control
capability
on on at the image registry level. Yeah.
Some sort of rule where you can see
that all images have to be built for
ARM 64 or something like that just to
yeah. I can see the use case for
that. Yeah. Alright. Let's let's see if I
can I can write a test? So I'm
gonna just butcher the one I copied from
that thing.
I'll just call it test test dot
wiggle.
Naming is the hardest part of of this
whole
Well, I wanna I always like to try
and pick things that might break stuff just
to see what happens. So so I'm gonna
test the MySQL
is not allowed. And I'm assuming this just
has to kind of reflect the JSON that
I have in my input. So
I'll just steal one of these.
And if
I remove that
oh, that should be I'm assuming I can
do a low and not allow. That's the
two assertions that the test and framework is
gonna make. Is there anything else there?
So it's so so like
other things, OPA, the test framework is very
minimal. The only thing you need to do
is name the test test underscore something. So
when you run OpenTest, it'll just look for
all the rules that are called test underscore
and then run those.
What you put inside of those rules is
entirely up to you. So
you could you could refer to anything. In
this case,
we were referring to allow, which is a
rule that we defined in a in a
in a policy in that example. So what
we wanna do in this case is actually
refer to the deny rule that you've got.
Right. Okay.
However,
remember, all rules are namespaced inside of a
package. Right? So in order to report to
deny,
we either have to be inside the same
package or we need to yeah. We need
to do that. And all rules are names
yeah. Oh, there we go. Perfect. Done. Okay.
So these, yeah, okay. So these packages have
to line up. I can then use this
deny with an input. That's the same that
everything has to start with Hooley. So what
I'm gonna do is this test to say
that this should be
denied with
Is that right?
So it
this will run. So why why don't we
run this, and and then we can kinda,
like, debug it and see kinda what happens.
Test test.
Yeah.
So why don't you just run just do
test
dash b
and then b as in bicycle,
and then just do dot.
Alright.
So all that's going on here is we're
saying
open test dot, which is just saying the
current directory. So it's gonna load all the
files in the current directory.
And it'll do that recursively, by the way.
So all the open tooling kinda works this
way. You can pass in a directory path
for any of the the file paths, and
it'll load all the files in that directory
as well as all the subdirectories and so
on. So it'll recursively load all the the
Regal and data files that it finds.
Dash b,
as in bicycle, tells the OpenTooling
to follow the, like, bundle layout. So what
that means is it'll load all the Rego
files that it finds
as well as all the
files called data dot JSON or data dot
YAML. So that's how you can load in,
like, raw JSON data if you want. Without
dash b can run it without dash b
and just see what happens.
Yeah. So what what happened there is it
tried to load all the data files as
well as all the YAML and JSON files
and then load them into data like, into
the data keyword in the language. And when
it did that, it it ran into some
problems. Like, it it tried to merge input
dot YAML and input two dot JSON together,
and it just couldn't do that because
well, because they're arrays, I think. Right? So
you can't really, like, merge arrays.
So we can we can just kinda, like,
avoid that problem by doing dash b, which
will cause it to ignore those those input
files.
Yeah. I mean,
I
what make this an array? Does it then
do the merge?
It will try to merge.
However, it's gonna
well, it might no. I think it's gonna
run into problems with the those arrays in
there, but try it out and see what
happens.
Merge error. Yeah. It's running into a merge
error on those on files. But if you
if you go to the, like, input YAML
and you just put a key at the
top level with, like
just just indent it by one and then
yeah. And then yeah.
And then perfect.
Yeah. Now it'll
be totally happy.
I'll put the JSON
to merger.
Well, is that because I've now changed the
format of that and not the rules? Got
is that an array?
I I stopped it being an array. Now
it's an array again.
If it's an array, it's gonna you can't
use an array at that level
for data.
Okay.
Anyway Let's not yeah. I'm gonna rattle on
the data. What I'm curious about is, like,
this test passed.
Right. And that's the that
let's let's finish on this then. So why
did this pass
when it's not a Hooly container image?
So so so the reason why it passed
is that, like, deny doesn't mean anything to
OPA. Deny is just a set,
and it happens to be it's a set.
So it's actually gonna always pass regardless of
whether or not there's a value inside of
that because that, like basically, the statement on
line four is it it's it's always true.
It's either an empty set or it's a
set that contains values.
So in order to, like, actually write this
test properly, what we wanna do is assert
on the val like, value of deny.
So we'd wanna say
deny
and and, like, these tests are are simpler
because allow is like a Boolean value. It's
either true or false. And so what we're
testing is, like, that it's either true or
it's false. And if you just say
allow and allow happens to be false,
then the test is gonna fail because one
of the because the statement in the body
of the test is false. Right? So,
yeah, so for this deny rule, what we'd
wanna do is test the actual
value of that deny set. So we'd wanna
say deny is nonempty
or deny contains error mess like, error messages.
Is that enough?
It's in this case, deny is a set.
So what you'd wanna do is declare an
empty set. So you could just say
you you can say set print, like, call
set say set, and then, like you would
in Python, you'd say set
low lowercase set.
K. So that failed because we're getting something
back from the deny rule, which is that
this is not a a hooly
image.
Right.
Wait. Hang on a second.
No. Wait. That that that that statement should've
Oh, no. I can't spell.
Yeah. Oh, there. Is that No. No. No.
There's something wrong with the logic. Hang on.
So
this should generate an error. So the set
should be nonempty.
So that should be set as like what
happens if you just select that whole I
just wanna make sure that we're not missing
something here. If you select, like, lines, whatever,
three through 29
four through 29, And you evaluate that.
Oh, I think I know what's wrong.
Okay. So deny is empty.
Problem is I renamed the input file. So
the task force pattern to be an input
dot JSON. No? No.
No. Remember what we did in the policy?
We made it so that it expects an
array for input.
Yep.
So in in main dot rego, it's expecting
input to be an array, but in the
test, we've just specified it as an object.
Ah, ah, okay. Gotcha. Gotcha. Gotcha.
Oh, yeah. There's nothing to do with the
input dot JSON because we're defining the input
We're in we're in the
Yep.
Alright.
And
if you select that again and run that,
does it
So evaluate.
Why?
So it's giving us one result back, and
it's saying that deny is empty.
But this says using input dot JSON and
not
this.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. That one's using input dot
JSON.
But it shouldn't matter. Like, it should replace
it with the
the value from inside the query.
So what am I what am I missing
here?
And
this yeah. That should still fail.
Can you
yeah. I mean, if you if you remove
the width part, like, width input as and
just do that same query, what is it?
Yeah. We could use coverage here to see
where it's failing. I think that's what we'll
end up doing.
So just select an eye now.
And then yeah. Okay. So that's that's behaving
as we'd expect.
K. So put the put the width back.
Yeah. So if you select deny
the whole thing, and then you can do
eval with coverage, and that'll show us what
lines.
Look for coverage.
Select toggle
evaluation coverage. Yeah.
So now go into main.Rego.
Oh, wait. Just why is it not the
highlighting is not showing up. Well, that's not
good.
I'm sure it's something I've done.
Yeah. I just can't see the
No. I made that hooly image, so that
would actually pass anyway. Right?
Well, it should be the set should be
nonempty now,
I would expect.
Can you just just copy this entire file
and paste it into the playground?
I could just delete it if you want.
Up to here? I wanna know why it
does or just paste the test below the
deny rule in the in the playground. Oh,
okay.
I guess I'll need to remove that duplicate
package.
Yeah. Let's go to the package. And then
and then select, like, 33 through
the bottom of them. Yeah. 258. And then
run click coverage
and then evaluate.
Okay. Now scroll up.
Wait a second.
Wait. It's different. We we are seeing a
value for deny
now.
Yeah. We did get And if you if
you just if you just evaluate the package,
test the test will pass, I think. Basically,
it'll be true.
Okay. Wait. So it okay. So it's doing
the right thing there. I don't understand why
and and we've got deny we've got an
assertion down below that says deny is non
empty. Yeah.
Okay.
So so
that worked. Right? Yeah. So that this this
is doing what we expect. Right? Deny is
not an empty set when it's evaluated with
that input.
So if I just set this to hooley.com,
then we should get test my SQL is
not allowed as false.
Yes.
Or it'll be emptively missing.
Or I guess it should
be an empty set. It should be an
empty set, but
what
is going on?
I'm good at breaking stuff. Like,
I just had I spend my actual day
programming just doing what's going on.
And so if you evaluate right now
oh,
okay. Sorry. This is I I I got
caught up in in the details here.
We're basically evaluating deny twice so that that
we're not assigning the value of deny
to a local variable. So the the value
of the in like, so, basically, like, you've
asked for deny on line 33,
and then you asked for it again on
line 60 or whatever it is down below.
On line
60, it's being evaluated with the input
on the on on the top right in
that pane.
But on line 33, it's being evaluated with
the input that we've defined in line inside
the policy.
Right. So I have to make I have
to assign the result here?
Yeah. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's what you'd
wanted. Is that? Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Sorry. Res.
Yeah. Now res is not able to empty
set.
Alright. And then I I should be able
to break that.
Yeah. That's right. There we go. There we
go. Okay. Sorry. I was going I was
going crazy. I I just wrote down and
looked at the look at the actual policy.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So
Okay. Cool. That
that makes sense to me now. Now I
know what was going on there. I just
assumed some something magic was happening between this
and then this So did I.
Yeah.
Alright. Well,
we'll leave it there. That was a fantastic
introduction to Open Policy Agent and Rago. And
a lot of things clicked for me now
just through this conversation and playing with a
a really, really impressive tool. I can see
so many different applications for this as well.
I can see why it's not just being
consumed and used by the Kubernetes community, but
by so much more. So I I just
wanna say thank you for joining me today.
That was that was great. And I really
appreciate your your input, your time, and especially
your patience there as I was kind of
breaking things and kicking them over. So thank
you for joining me today. Yeah. It's been
a pleasure, David. Thanks a lot. Alright. Well,
have a a great afternoon.
I'll enjoy my evening, and I will speak
to you again soon. Thank you, Taron. Yeah.
Cheers. Take care. Bye bye.